architectural plans are extremely easy
to read when you understand the code
behind them what's going on guys my name
is david thomas and welcome back to the
channel if you're new here firstly thank
you so much for joining me on this
channel we talk all things architecture
and technology today we're going through
how architectural plans are drawn and
how you can read them as somebody who
isn't potentially involved in the
architecture industry 24 7 but you might
be building your own home you might be
doing a renovation or you might just
simply have an interest in architecture
download this construction pdf off the
internet and today i'm going to walk you
through exactly what you need to be
looking for to understand every single
bit of detail
so starting off with the site plan the
site plan is basically a contextual
overview of everything you need to know
about the project and where it's
situated most of the time you're going
to have some sort of boundary lines
around the side in this case they're
quite evident because we have setback
lines directly from the boundary to the
corner of the building all these little
lines going through the page which are
usually grayed out in some form or some
fashion are generally indicating the
contours of the site and by contours i
mean how that site is falling up and
down left and right if you don't get
enough information from these contour
lines you also have these individual
small little hot spots so if i was to
zoom right in you'd see that that is
6.755
above the australian height datum which
is a standard measurement here in
australia so understanding that we know
that it's 6.755 at that back left corner
and if i go to the front right corner
it's
9.208 which means we have almost a 3.5
meter fall from the back left hand
corner to the bottom right hand corner
of this page
just by simply looking at these hotspots
we can understand how the levels and how
the ground works we can't always build
on flat sides we can't always have a
perfect luxury of that so sometimes we
will have a lot of contour lines over
the page continuing on into the page and
the actual architecture itself the
proposed driveway here is going to be
some sort of concrete which is indicated
by the dots throughout that actual
texture so there is a series of
universally accepted and recognized
hatches for architectural drawings so
everybody can consistently know what
they're looking at by simply having a
quick look the rest of this page
basically just tells us where things are
in proportion to the boundary lines and
where they sit on that block itself so
overall this page is really just telling
us where the house sits and how high up
it is moving down to the ground floor
plan we start understanding what the
actual internals of the house look like
so if i was to zoom in to the corner of
this wall here we could see that this is
a timber frame wall and that right here
for example that door is a 920 door
which means it has an opening leaf of
820 millimeters we have a few critical
bits of information here that we need to
understand when looking at the ground
floor plan first of all we have our
elevation markers which are always
represented on the outside of the
building looking in towards so if i was
to look at e01 that is basically looking
a front on at that building if we were
only to see it in a 2d flat elevation
point of view so we can recognize
difference between a section and an
elevation by simply utilizing the e01
marker or the e02 marker understanding
that the e stands for elevation then on
the other hand we have our section
markers which are sometimes represented
as an s01 or they are lettered in this
case so here we have an a we have a b
and we have a c each one of these
markers is quickly indicating to you
what page it can be found on now
obviously this page has been completely
desensitized and there's no information
because it comes readily on the internet
but we can see that section b can be
found on a06 so in that instance it
would most likely be the sixth page for
this project here so if we were to talk
about the dimensions on the outside the
house is usually broken up into
quadrants so everything on the bottom of
the page will annotate everything on
half of that building towards the bottom
the top reflects the top half and the
left and right dimensions usually
reflect that building split in half
again looking at it on each
representative side in this instance it
is very simple building there isn't a
vast amount of information that we need
multiple multiple layers of dimensions
it's relatively simple so if i zoom into
this top section of the building we can
see that these dimensions are working
from the outside in so starting with the
930 it's basically telling you from the
edge of the wall to that window which is
window 0 6 in this instance we have 930
mil and then that window is 2.41 wide
moving back to the next dimension line
we're talking about the actual internals
of the building so they are clearly
marked here with bed one bed one so you
know exactly what you're looking at and
isn't hard to read looking at this
simply we know it's a 90 millimeter stud
wall it is for 4.1 meters wide for the
bedroom and then again another 90
millimeter stud wall followed by a 2.2
meter walk-in robe and then the kitchen
living dining spaces we can continue to
read this set of plans accordingly
moving further and further out and
further and further in depending on how
the dimension lines work themselves on
the ground floor plan there isn't too
much more that you really need to
understand and know most of it is quite
graphical and quite informative so we
can actually see what we're looking at
we know that picture is very universal
for a toilet we know that's very
universal for a bath a shower a hand
basin a trough and then a washing
machine so some things are very just
generic and very universal so we don't
really have to explain them too much
some things that usually aren't clearly
indicated on most architectural plans
and some people don't understand what
they're looking at is our actual
understanding of the rls and the
finished floor levels so in this
instance we know that this dining room
is at plus zero zero and so is the
garage there is no step down between
these two so therefore if you're walking
in from your garage to your main living
space it's completely flush in the
concrete in some instances you will
notice a minus symbol in the garage or a
minor symbol somewhere in the house to
indicate a sunken area or potentially a
positive symbol to say plus 500 that way
you know you're going to need to take
some steps up to get to that space now
continuing on with the elevation markers
if we were to look at these elevation
markers we'd see e1 and e2 moving to the
next page we'll again see e1 and e2 on
each side that's basically indicating to
us that e1 is e1 at the top and e2 is e2
on the left hand side looking at e2 as a
basic understanding of an elevation what
we really are looking for is the
architectural expression on the outside
so elevations will tell you
predominantly about textures materials
colors rather than anything structural
in this instance we do sometimes speak
about the roof pictures because it's
simple and easy to understand in this
instance but most of the time we're just
talking about actual architectural
aluminium frames and james hardy axon
cladding on the outside it does also
tell us the heights of our windows and
the overall seal height too so it is an
added bit of information that we get
from the elevation sometimes our
elevations will come in color most of
the time they'll come in black and white
it really depends on the architectural
firm for me personally i will have both
black and white and color elevations to
make sure that no information is missed
across the board the next page again
represents the exact same information
but of the two separate
elevations at the same time on this
elevation three we have two new lines so
we have an fgl which is a future ground
level and we have an ngl which is a
natural ground level
understanding that most of the time when
you're reading an elevation the natural
ground level is an indication from the
boundary line itself where the house
actually sits could be very different
and it is also indicated if there is a
huge difference in that
natural ground level on this elevation
so now just looking at this set of plans
i can see that there is quite a large
amount of sand required to fill up this
block to be able to actually build this
house flat so the natural ground level
is quite low the new ground level when
all that sand comes in is going to be
significantly higher we can also
understand what our ceiling height is
going to be throughout that house and in
this instance it is very basic it is
very simple we're going 0 to 2.7 so we
know that our ceiling level in that
house is going to be 2.7 meters
throughout the next page is very similar
to our elevations it is now structural
sections so if i scroll back up to my
floor plan and zoom into one of my
sectional details section a on page a06
we don't have any pages we know that it
is section six so now coming back to
those sections section a right here will
indicate to us all sorts of structural
information so if i zoom in to this
section here we know that the slab on
the outside porch is one course down so
86 millimeters compared to the entry
itself we know we have some sort of
curved cornices and we know our ceiling
sits at 2.7 above understanding generic
architectural expression we can also see
that we're showing timber frames in this
instance timber frames are shown with a
simple box and a cross whereas metal
stud purlins are shown more indicatively
of the shape they are so if it's a c
purlin it'll be drawn as a c if it's a
zed you'll see a zed i could also
understand that this squiggly line up
the top is a form of insulation so we're
going to need some sort of bulk
insulation at the top and we also have a
truss holding up our entire roof
now i can make that assumption or i can
go across to the actual annotations on
this document which will tell me that
we're using bulk sealing insulation on
top we're using 10 millimeter
plasterboards and we also have a termite
management system underneath the slab as
well so each individual line is usually
annotated in some way shape or form in a
section this is a very basic section
there isn't a lot of information going
on sometimes you might also have a
sectional detail marker which is going
to be a dashed outline with a little d01
next to it as an instance for example
this box cutter would be something i
would detail very heavily so that people
understood exactly how it was to be
built whereas in this instance they're
just relying on the builder to be able
to provide some sort of box gutter to be
able to then actually drain away that
water from the roof but at the same time
speaking about that roof and speaking
about that box gutter looking at that
section we can tell that that upstand is
completely hiding that roof so that
whole section of roof is completely
concealed now there is some ambiguity in
this set of documentation because you
can see a minus one course here whereas
when we went back to our original floor
plan that floor plan did not reflect any
set down in that garage so this
documentation set isn't perfect it has
some errors which we've already picked
up on
but it's a good way to understand
architectural documentation this next
section is exactly the same as the one
above it just goes into some different
elements of the construction and the
house and we just really start
understanding how the building works
itself now as an architect i can pick up
more errors in this documentation for
example that timber stud going all the
way to the ground will completely rot
out but that isn't my judgment call to
make on this set of drawings moving
further on we can start seeing our roof
plan our roof plan is a very basic
understanding of what we really need to
know there's not too much that goes on a
roof plan usually there's some hips and
valleys there's some sort of truncation
that goes along in this instance all we
can see is a number of vents the extents
of the building below and what kind of
roof shedding we're using we can also
get an understanding of how that roof is
going to go so one's going to fall that
way another one's going to fall that way
and the last one is going to fall back
the same direction
so in this instance this roof plan is
merely just telling us some basic
information of how each roof falls where
the gutters are where the barges are and
what each individual item is next we
have an our electrical plan which is a
little bit more in-depth and a little
harder to understand if you don't know
what you're looking at in this instance
i have no sort of electrical legend so
i'm guessing there'd be some sort of
documentation to go with this actual set
of plans but if i was to zoom in and use
an educated guess of what's going on we
can see that in this toilet we have our
dashed line to our light switch which
also connects to our exhaust fan so that
indicates to me that one light switch
will trigger both your fan and your
exhaust fan at the exact same time
whereas in this bathroom for instance we
have one going to the exhaust fan and
another going to the light switch so
that means i can turn on my light and
turn on my exhaust at separate times not
at once now this is something that's
really easy to pick up on a set of plans
and it might be something that bugs you
in person so if you can read a set of
electrical plans like this on a very
basic house you can understand that you
do not want one switch for both sets of
items you want two switches and that is
sometimes dependent on the national
construction code and the regulations
behind it so the same principle applies
to the rest of the house where the lines
basically end is where that switch is
going to be how those switches work so
that's a three-way switch which means
three points on the wall you can turn it
off and on a two-way switch you can turn
it off and on on two points and then we
have our power points down below so 350
millimeters above the ground we'll have
a double gpo two double gpo is down here
then it appears like some sort of aerial
antenna connection to
the theater which makes plenty of sense
and then the same information on the
bedrooms and the ensuites so in this
ensuite toilet here for example we do
have our two lines to two different
connections which means we can turn that
light on we can turn that exhaust fan on
we don't have to turn on both the same
time overall that is the basic
understanding of the electrical plan
again there would be some sort of legend
to tell me what that light is what that
light is what that light is and what
every single
annotation is on this page however we
don't have that information in this
instance so we're just guessing and
assuming based on general knowledge that
that in the middle of a living room
would be a light globe on the ceiling
now our next page appears to be some
sort of internal room elevations and
internal room layouts so basically what
they've done is they've cropped one
section of that building to basically
give you a lot more information about
what needs to happen so in this instance
k1 is looking at very similar as an
elevation just being an internal
elevation into the kitchen and k2 is
looking backwards towards the island
bench we again see some dimensions
wrapping around this kitchen layout to
basically annotate a bit more so we know
what's going on in a bit more depth same
as the internal elevations
now we can see that we're going to have
drawers an oven couple cupboards and a
dishwasher recess a big window and an
exposed range hood so that information
you can't actually understand from
looking at a floor plan you do need to
see it in some sort of 2d elevation or
3d
annotation so you can actually
understand what's going on so these
sorts of drawings are actually extremely
useful and a lot of the time they are
missed in architectural firms so usually
the client will just say no don't need
them i'll sort that out myself
but when a builder goes to build it they
have no idea what they're doing
so this really helps people price it and
helps them know what they're building
similar to how we looked at this kitchen
layout we can look at this bathroom
layout we only have one b1 looking
basically directly back so if we zoom
into this b1 section we can get quite a
bit of information
basically assuming from the information
that i'm given here i can understand and
analyze that the light gray shaded
patches would be some sort of tiles and
then the white bits would just be
painted wall or painted [ __ ] rock there
isn't too much information on this
internal room elevation but a lot of it
can be assumed i'm guessing this cwt
would reference back to again some sort
of external document same as that shower
same as the mirror two so you'd have a
set of specifications that would say
this cwt is a 600 by 1200 tile or
whatever the instance might be and again
looking front on we can understand we
have two cupboards two drawers 200
millimeters of tiles upstand and then a
mirror above so that simple internal
elevation gives us a lot of information
that sometimes wouldn't be portrayed at
all in a 2d floor plan at all anyway
that is all for me today guys thank you
so much for watching i hope you learned
everything you're looking for here in
this one video today if you did make
sure you smash that like button down
below if you truly loved it make sure
you smash the subscribe button and like
always i'll see you next monday